[تصفيق]
مساء الخير عايزه اشكر فريق العمل الحقيقه
مقدم مجهود ممتاز
المجموعه اللي اتكلمت معي مجموعه على
مستوى من الثقافه الحقيقه ابهرني واسعدني
جدا
فالحياه بقدم لهم تحيه كبيره جدا جدا
[تصفيق]
موضوع مهم وهو الحوار ما بين الافراد
وبعضها لبعض
في اغنيه لسيده ورده الجزائريه ما اعرفش
انتم فاكرينها ولا لا ولا قديمه اغنيه
بتقول بتونس بيك حد فاكرها
باتونس بيك وانت معايا الاغنيه دي بتفكرني
دايما بصديقه ليا اسمها غاده كل ما تكلمني
في تليفون تقول لي فاطمه انا عايزه اتونس
معك
فالحقيقه الجمله بتسعدني جدا بتونس معك
فاقول لها يعني ايه هتونس معاكي فتقول لي
عايزه ادردش معاكي
فالدردشه في حد ذاتها يعني المساله بتسعد
اللي بيمارسها
الدردشه بمعنى الفضفضه اني افضفض مع حد
مرتاحاله اتكلم معاه في موضوع
مشغلني
عشر دقائق فضفاضه كده مع انسان مرتاحه
معاه ممكن تغني عن طبيب نفسي
وتغني عن امراض نفسيه طبعا
الدردشه بتخلينا
نقدر ننظم افكارنا يعني عندي فكره مشغوله
بها مع
مجموعه افكار المتعدده داخله في بعضها
فلما اتناقش مع حد بحبه
وبرتاح معاه
بقدر بلور هذه الفكره وبقدر ان انا اتحول
الى
اخرج بنتائج او افكار جديده عن هذه الفكره
عشان كده بقول لكم ان كلمه دردشه دي كلمه
ظريفه جدا اتمنى ان كل واحد فيكم يمارسها
مع بقيه الاسره بتاعته
وعشان كده عايزه اسالكوا على حاجه
عايزه اعرف كم واحد في القاعه هنا عمل
حوار مع احد افراد الاسره هذا الاسبوع في
موضوع يخصه لمده مثلا 10 دقائق
بنوع من انواع الحماميه والدفء الانساني
وفي ناس ابتدوا يرفعوا ايديهم اهو ههه
جميل ههه
طيب احنا عايزين العدد يزيد يا جماعه
عايزين الحوار يبقى هو اساس الحياه
الانسانيه اللي احنا عايشينها عايزه
الحوار هو اللي يسيطر على حياتنا ويسيطر
على علاقاتنا الاجتماعيه ليه الحوار مهم
ما بين الاشخاص وبعضهم البعض مهم جدا لانه
من خلال الحوار انا بقدر افهم
اللي قدامي بيحب ايه بيكره ايه
بقدر احط ايدي على المفاتيح الخاصه واقدر
اقلل من حجم سوق التفاهم اللي بيحصل بيننا
وبين بعض
عندي صديق من الاصدقاء الحقيقه
دائما يعني يعبر له عن غضبه الشديد من انه
والده شخصيه كتومه جدا
الانسان الكاتوم انت ما بتعرفش هتدخل له
منين هتتكلم معاه منين تفتح معاه موضوع
ازاي
معاناه صديقي ده
بيتكلم فيها عن انه في حواجز كبيره نفسيه
واجتماعيه بينه وبين
والده طيب الحوار
المهم في الاسره لاسباب مختلفه جدا اهم
سبب منها هو ان الحوار مع والدي او والدتي
او احد افراد الاسره بيلعب دور كبير في
ان احنا يحصل عندنا نوع من انواع الاشباع
العاطفي الاشباع العاطفي دي جمله طبعا
جمله كبيره جدا
جمله تفكرني بالاشباع الاشباع ده مش مرتبط
بالمعده يا جماعه
الاشباع فقط مرتبط بالمعده ده دي فكر
تنا الاتانا الاشباع العاطفي هو ان انا
اقعد
يعني اسرتي تحتويني احتواء كافي ومن خلال
هذا الاحتواء اشعر بنوع من الشبع العاطفي
طيب لو انا انسان عندي نوع من انواع
الاشباع العاطفي اللي هو من خلال الاسره
اهم شيء انه يحصل هذا الاشباع العاطفي من
الاسره لما اخرج بره اطار المنزل
وبواجه صعوبات الحياه طبعا وما اكثرها
لو انا انسان عندي اشباع عاطفي وعامل حوار
مع اسرتي ومع الافراد المحيطين بيا في
المجتمع اللي انا عايش فيه بجد ان انا
بقدر اواجه هذه الصعوبات بشكل جيد جدا
يعني احس ان انا عندي شخصيه مستقله هذا
السبب الاساسي عدم قبول الاختلاف بيننا
وبين بعض لما يكون الاب
رافض ان هو
يعني يقبل ابنه كما هو بكل اختلافاته
اختلافه في الملبس اختلافه في طريقه
التفكير اختلافه في طريقه الكلام في بعض
الاحيان
صديقتي دي دايما تشتكي ان هي عايزه تقص
شعرها
جارسون
ووالدتها طبعا شايفه انه ايه اللي انت
هتعمليه في نفسك ده ده حاجه مش حلوه وشكلك
وحش فده بيولد نوع من انواع الصراع في
الاسره سبب الصراع الاول هو عدم القبول
طيب انا النهارده لو في المجتمع بتاعي وفي
طبقه غير الطبقه الاعلى مني طبقه مثلا
نعتبرها الطبقه المتوسطه
لو انا ما عنديش قبول بهذه الطبقه
يعني
حاسس بنوع من الموائمه معها بيحصل بيني
وبينها نوع من انواع الصراع الطبقي لو نفس
الشيء بشعر ان في ثقافه بتسود في المجتمع
هذا هذه الثقافه لو انا ما عنديش قبول
ليها بيصبح عندي صراع ثقافي يبقى اذا اول
حاجه لابد ان احنا نعملها عشان ما يحصلش
نوع من انواع الصراع بيني وبين الاخرين
اني اقبل الشخص اللي قدامي كما هو يعني
الام اللي هي
رافضه وجود تغيرات شكليه
وحقيقيه في
الفتاه اللي هي بنتها اللي خلفتها زي ما
يعني عايزاها تبقى صوره نسخه طبق الاصل
منها لا اقبلي بنتك زي ما هي وكمان يعني
نفسها لابد ان هي تقبل الام كما هي لو حصل
هذا النوع من القبول
طبعا
انه هيحصل
ذوبان
ونقلل من حجم الصراعات اللي حاصله من
المهم ان انا ااكد عليكم انه المنزل هو
السكن المنزل هو راح بيت الراحه يعني
منطقه الراحه اللي انا بقعد فيها لا انتظر
احكام من الاخرين عشان كده من المهم ان
احنا ناسس بيوتنا بحيث ان هي تكون خاليه
من الصراعات احط روشته
لخلو المنزل من الصراعات لابد ان اول حاجه
احطها وهي اني اقبل الاخر نقبل الاخر ازاي
انه مهما كان مختلف عني
فانا قبلاه زي ما هو
قبولي للاخر بيخلي نخفض من معدل الصراع ما
بيننا وما بين بعض الحاجه التانيه وهي
القراءه نهتم بها على مستوى ثقافتنا
القراءه ليه يعني كتير قوي هيقول لك قراءه
ايه اللي دخلها في موضوع الحوار
واهميه يعني
ذوبان الفجوه ما بين
الاجيال وبعضها لبعض القراءه بتخليك تتخيل
نفسك او تتخيل الاخرين في مواقف مختلفه
هذه المواقف لما تتخيلها هتقدر ان انت
يعني تعذر الاخر تعذر الاخر بمعنى ايه
بمعنى انه
بتسامح معك لو هو بيعمل موقف معين فانا
نتيجه قراءات المختلفه بقدر ان انا احط
نفسي مكانه واقدر اتسام ح مع موقفه واقدر
اعذره
وطبعا قديما قال الفيلسوف احكم الناس
اعذرهم للناس فاحنا نتعلم جزء من يعني
ان احنا نكسر الفجوه ما بيننا وما بين
الاخرين ان احنا نتعلم مع زر الاخرين مع
زور الاخرين يعني احط نفسي مكانه
واقول احتمال يكون كان ما يقصدش كذا عايز
يعمل حاجه مش سيئه الى هذا الشكل
بكده نقدر نفض الاشتباك قليلا لما اتجه
للقراءه والثقافه فدي اول خطوات ان انا
افض الاشتباك ما بين الاجيال وبعضها لبعض
الحوار بيساعدني افهم الشخص اللي قدامي
مشاكله ايه اقدر اساعده ازاي يعني لو انت
محتاج مساعده انا هعرف ازاي لو انت مش
بتتكلم معايا
لو مش بنعبر لبعض عن افكارنا هيبقى صعب
جدا ان احنا نتقبل بعض
ونتعامل مع بعض بشكل جيد
الخطوه الثانيه اللي انا باكد عليها بعد
القراءه انه يبقى بيننا وبين بعض نوع من
انواع التسامح تسامح بمعنى ايه بمعنى اني
اعرف ان انت انسان والدتي انسانه والدتي
انسانه عاديه احيانا
بتكون بتكون عندها ظروف خاصه ووارد جدا ان
هي
ما تقدرش يعني تخرج عن شعورها في بعض
الاوقات
ومطلوب مني انا كابن ان انا
احتوي والدتي زي ما هي بتحتويني في بعض
اللحظات
انا عارفه ان الكلام ده ممكن يكون غريب
لانه الطبيعي ان احنا الابن الام هي اللي
بتحتوي الابن او الاب هو اللي بيحتوي
الولد او الاولاد بشكل عام لكن لو فكرنا
في في قصرنا
الجيل الكبير بتاعنا اللي احنا متربيين
معاه على انه بني ادم فكره البني
ادم بني ادم يعني ايه يعني عنده غلطات
نتسامح معاها ونتقبلها عنده
يعني عنده عيوب عادي جدا زيي بالظبط زي
الابن ما بيبقى عنده عيوب وابوه بيبقى
متقبلها
من الحاجات المهمه اللي انا احب اتكلم
عليها في
بخصوص الاسره انه في نقطتين مهمين جدا
يعني من المهم ان احنا نشتغل عليهم قوي في
اسرنا
اول حاجه انه الاسره بتحب الطفل ده يعني
انا لما اكون زوجه
منتظره طفل انا بحبه بلا سبب بحبه بلا اي
هدف وهو ده معنى الحب غير المشروط مش
عارفه حد سمع عن المصطلح ده قبل كده
جميل الحب غير المشروط من الحاجات اللي
احنا عايزين نغزيها جدا في الاسره المصريه
لانه الحب غير المشروط معناه اني لا انتظر
منك شيء انا بحبك فقط
وبتعامل معك
يعني لبعض بعض الاسر طبعا بيقع في غلطه
رهيبه وهي انه هات بوسه لعمه عشان يحبك
ههه
فطبعا دي بتبقى غلطه فاحشه لان انا بعلم
الطفل انه لابد انه يعمل شيء عشان عمه
يحبه او عشان طنط تحبه او عشان والده يحبه
والطبيعي انه في الاسره المصريه
انه يعني
يبقى في حب غير مشروط
الحب غير المشروط مهم جدا في الحياه
المصريه مش عارفه
الحاجه التانيه اللي عايزه اتكلم عليها
بخصوص الاسره المصريه
الحب غير المشروط احنا اتكلمنا عليه
واتكلمنا على نقطه الاشباع العاطفي اللي
لابد ان البيت يكون هو مصدر الاساسي لهذا
الاشباع الحوار اللي انا بقوله ده يا
جماعه يعني يصب فيه نقطه اساسيه وهي انه
التعايش في المجتمع المصري بشكل اوسع يعني
لما يحصل نوع من انواع التعايش في الاسره
ينتقل بسهوله انه بما اني قبلت نفسي في
هذه الاسره
فاذا على مدار الاوسع بخصوص التعايش في
المجتمع بشكل عام
اجد نفسي قبلت الاخر في هذا المجتمع وده
شفناه في مصر قديما هنجد انه كان في
جنسيات مختلفه كتير جدا وكان في نوع من
انواع التعايش انا
باريس وعشت فيها حوالي 8 سنوات
كان من عوامل الصدمه بتاعتي او الزهول
يعني شعرت بيه حجم التعايش اللي موجود في
هذا المجتمع التعايش بين الجنسيات
المختلفه طبعا كلنا عارفين فرنسا بنجد
فيها مثلا عدد المصريين كبير جدا عدد
العرب اا المختلفين سواء مغاربه او غيره
كتير جدا عرض عدد الاتراك برده على نفس
الحكايه برده عدد كبير
فحجم التعايش اللي حاصل في دوله زي فرنسا
ما بين كل هذه الجنسيات سببه الاول انه ما
فيش احكام على بعضنا البعض ان احنا بنقبل
بعض بلا اي حسابات بقى بالك زي ما انت انت
مختلف لكن انا قبلتك زي ما انت
والحاجه الثانيه طيب اختم بقى خلاص ارجو
ارجو بس من كل واحد فيكم انه يبص في في
وجه الاخر انت تبص في وش القفر وتقول له
انا بقبلك كما انت وليس عليك ان تتغير حتى
اقبلك
وممتنه جدا جدا جدا لوجودكم شكرا
[تصفيق]